let's talk about crypto what do we think
about
bitcoin's crash is this something what
does this have
most to do with china china
my take is everything that you just said
in the intro teeing up
china and climate and all these things
are noise
okay what's the signal watch the tape
that this is
this is the um as the paradigm folks
sort of coined this term
uh bubbles as it go to market every time
that
bitcoin will always have a run up it
will always have a crash down
um and so far it has been very effective
at
using that run-up to bring more people
into the ecosystem
it doesn't crash down below the level
that it was at before the
run-up uh it is um you know the crypto
community
whether intentionally or not is very
effective at using hype
to increase the surface area of the
ecosystem
it is unpredictable to me what the
future
sort of bubble bursts what will cause
those what
really caused this one what caused
previous ones all we know is i think
this will keep happening
and david yeah
i think um i i mostly agree with
ben i think though one thing that is
uh i should have been thinking about
before this was kind of in the back of
my mind but
this uh particular cycle
has brought my mind to is
the benefit of bitcoin versus everything
else in crypto is it doesn't change
right but it also doesn't change
and so much is changing in the world and
i it's got me thinking
about change well it's it's locked you
know like
there's there's a finite number of them
oh it's used
in that just just like the whole
ecosystem like satoshi is gone like
there is no
development there's no changing there's
no innovation in bitcoin it is what it
is and that's attractive like you know
the rules aren't going to change
uh but ethereum and all the other
protocols out there and everything
happening in d5 like
there is so much innovation happening so
fast in crypto
that i do wonder if that is actually a
better part of the ecosystem
to be in reality versus bitcoin
i have to agree with you there i've
always said i think if
bitcoin does get replaced as the most
attractive crypto
it would be because the other cryptos
have
a much better use case people become
more engaged with the better use case
and like gold bullion or silver
certificates
or whatever came before it it you just
have more energy in the in ethereum you
have more energy
and something more difficult there's
more going on and it's more excitement
and people just sort of lean towards
what's more exciting
are you seeing this like i'm definitely
seeing all the especially
like younger gen z not not gen x like me
uh folks uh ambitious founders people
who want to go work at companies
they are all going into crypto defy that
is
number one there's estimation i think
there's a
it's i don't think it's the number one
destination there's a lot of energy
there
and you you may have this like first
generation of believers who are kind of
in the
let's call them uh anarchist slash
you know societal outcasts people who
were
libertarians maybe financial crisis yeah
fight against the machine
kind of wall street occupy wall street
folks
um i think they are giving way to a
generation of finance
savvy millennials and gen zers who i
would
describe more as the robin hood crypto
like the robin hood coinbase
generation that they're so sophisticated
about this stuff that they're doing puts
and calls and
leveraging themselves up i mean a
hundred times leverage on your bitcoin i
think a lot of
what happened this time around for this
dip has to do with leverage
and i don't know if we can statistically
prove that
because everything is so opaque even
though it's supposed to not be okay yeah
i think that's why you saw the whole
crypto asset class get whacked because
people are getting margin calls
and yes whatever set this off i think
was probably your right either of you
ever
come close to a margin call either of
you ever have margin that's a
significant proportion no
one i will never use margin see this is
the thing like i i don't even i can't
even com
i mean i have a margin line i suppose
that one of my bank
my brokerages that i don't tap actually
i have it at two of my brokerages now
think about it
i don't really tap it um but it's there
i guess but i would never want to live
like that
who wants to live like that being yeah i
i have enough other things causing me
stress in my life that that
doesn't feel worth it to me yeah so i
mean but just think about it what if
when we were 22 years old
we had leverage on our 10 000 worth of
savings
pushing us to put 50 000 into markets
like there's a lot of young people who
are living with that
you know if it does if even if they have
the risk of ruin what's the risk of
ruining 10k
and maybe they go into debt for 10k i
don't know like
is it because you know the robin hood
suicide tragedy uh
was i would be careful well i would be
careful attributing
any putting that specific case aside any
time you have over a million people
using a service you will have
not occurred so it might think it was a
robin hood suicide it could be a suicide
fair that occurred where you know
trading might have been involved in a
person's decision but
you know a healthy normal person is not
going to kill themselves over using
cryptocurrency or whatever they might
have the grounding for it
i think it's really hard with that
attribution theory but anyways
so can i so one interesting thing that
i've been ruminating on in crypto and
it's interesting as we start to talk
about margin being available like
jason as you know david and i have spent
the last month and a half
like hundreds of hours deep in berkshire
hathaway research
yeah and while i have become
increasingly excited about
the future of of crypto in particular
defy
it is this crazy mental thrashing to go
back and forth between being a relative
crypto bull and saying like
bubble bubbles has a go to market
strategy you know we'll continue to see
this over and over again
it kind of keeps going up and also
having warren buffett in the back of my
head
and of course charlie saying these
things have no intrinsic value what do
you mean by the dip the dip
is only should only exist relative to
some intrinsic value of something
and the only intrinsic value of
especially bitcoin but you could argue
all cryptocurrencies is
what you believe that other people will
believe that it should be in the future
it doesn't have
a set of underlying profits it doesn't
have a set of underlying cash flows
i think ethereum and d5 is different
because there it is truly a distributed
computer
you can sort of build interesting
applications on top of it
but the wild rashing that has been
happening at least for me david i don't
know if you feel the same way of
by the dip versus no intrinsic value is
like a
total war in my head